uh dr vasudevan
has a broad range of research interests
but primarily she is a director of a
program called the systems medicine
program at georgetown university medical
center and we're excited to have her
here because i think that she brings a
unique insight into the role of
information technologies in medicine
she deals with a broad cohort of
international students
so any one of you that is really
interested
can benefit from understanding why she
started this program
what does she teach your students how is
it done how potentially you might want
to register for a program like that and
where do students that finish that
program go after they complete the
training
i also
want to introduce briefly
a couple of speakers that will be
picking up uh from the topic that dr
vasuvan will be
sharing on
the next speaker after that will be
alice caimans she's a strategic project
and program manager at google cloud and
she will speak about some of the
strategic initiatives that they are
undertaking at google to make various
training resources to be available to uh
those who are interested to incorporate
cloud into their
uh skill sets
um then we will hear from dr adelaide
rhodes she's a principal computational
biologist at a company called
cultivarium
and she will speak about bioinformatics
as the career options so many of us are
interested in research but there's also
the industry path and so she will
address that from her own personal
experience
we will then go on to hear from several
uh
accomplished speakers from south america
and those will include dr giorgios papas
from brazil
dr gabriel gaddy
who is originally also from brazil but
now works at cam 4 therapeutics in the
us
mr silver ceballos
who is
in costa rica
mr pierro
gasco who is in peru
and we will tie all of these topics
together in a group discussion where we
have um
dr rajida
gio chavez and miss maria victoria luz
who will speak about some of these
opportunities both in the u.s
and in
south america so
sona i will unmute you now
sorry about that
okay i believe you should be able to
meet yourself yeah okay um
you can all hear me correct
yeah is the volume good okay good um
thank you alia thank you so much uh for
the wonderful introduction and um thank
you all all the participants who are
here
um i think um the previous sessions have
been amazing and i think
most of uh the introduction and the
foundations for my talk has been laid
out pretty well
uh which is that everyone here
probably will agree that bioinformatics
is extremely important
and there's so much data and there are
lots and lots of challenges that all of
us are facing um
and what i'm going to be talking to you
with in the next 20 minutes or so
um is to tell you the biggest challenge
right now um in addition to all the data
and processing uh processing of the data
and everything else
we need to
train um the next generation
and in fact we have to train ourselves
uh on how to handle this big data and
what are we going to how are we going to
mine meaningful information from all of
this data
um and
[Music]
create
meaningful resources for the next
generation of students
from different disciplines
and of course spine biotechnology is
leading in that effort providing
different resources and courses and
everything else
so i'm going to share my screen here
okay i hope you can see mice yeah i
think you need to switch the screens we
can see okay
presenter
okay give me one second
is that better
your screen is not shown right now oh
it's not okay
yep now it's great yeah that's okay
thank you
complications with
so many different monitors here
okay so today i'm going to talk to you
about
systems medicine a new and evolving
emerging discipline
um that that we created at georgetown um
more importantly i'm going to focus on
how why and whom should we teach systems
medicine to
so first i'm sure all of you are
wondering what is systems medicine
because it's not become a lingo
that's commonly used by a lot of people
and it's getting popular right now so
systems medicine to give a formal
definition of it
it's a novel approach to medicine it is
a first step on the path to personalized
medicine
and i'm sure living through the panda
make all of us realize that um each of
us have different symptoms uh different
reactions to vaccines and therapeutics
and wondering why even within a whole a
similar household we have different um
reactions to all of these different
things
so systems medicine is based on computer
models in which vast amounts of clinical
data is uh used
to analyze the health of individual
patients
it also brings a humongous promise to
further our understanding of diseases
mechanisms
and also boost the efficacy of
treatments
and of course at the end of the day all
of us want to cut costs of health care
um and so it is actually one aspect of
what we call precision medicine
practicing medicine precisely
that reaches individual
care
so practical definitions of systems
medicine that all of us are very
familiar with
is it's a multi-disciplinary field
that looked looks at an individual as a
whole
and it uses systems biology and
computational sciences and omix
technologies to help solve biomedical
problems
and of course it is not necessarily the
future but it's also the current uh
practice
that all of us have realized um that um
the summary of it is one size does not
fit all so i actually call this
one size does not fit all medicine so
what does this mean it means that
say two patients
who have similar symptoms
have similar findings or diagnosis
um and in the same disease and given the
same drug
but both these patients react
differently to these drugs so of course
we all found out why
to patients with the same symptoms and
same underlying everything conditions
react differently to drugs
and of course we all kind of know
with all the data what the reasons
behind this could be
so why does drug response vary
among different
populations of people right individual
variation
of course it's all
at the underlying
genomic levels genetic differences uh
single nucleated polymorphisms that
exist between two individuals
or single nucleotide variants
that we call
these single nucleotide changes
of course it also could be
ethnicity
age
genetic factors
drug drug interactions
and environment plays a big role
of course we are all now
focusing our attention also to nutrition
and of course also the focus has been on
a microbiome i'm sure everyone in this
audience knows
the importance of microbiome and the
fascinating
concepts and realization we have come to
today that we have more
uh genes from these microorganisms that
exist in each part of our body than our
own genes as well so they are actually
taking more control over all of this so
there are different factors
uh that are actually responsible for
individual variation that exist
um
so why are we talking about all of this
um right now and the reason of course
we're all talking about all of this is
of course we are in the midst of an era
of big biological data
and i just put the panda make in
parenthesis with the hope that we are
going to say goodbye to it uh hopefully
soon um and so i don't want to feel like
we're living still living
in the middle of this but of course the
pandemic has also caused a lot of
realization for us and also uh
generated a huge amount of data for us
to
um a mine to understand these individual
variations um
specifically with respect to uh the
disease kovid19
and a revolution in medical practice in
the 21st century
and of course we can't forget where it
all started it all started with the
human genome project almost 17 to 18
years ago
and of course at that point all of us
celebrated um
that we are going to say goodbye to
diseases and we also
realize we also thought that we all
understand every single diseases
because we understood how many genes the
human genome project generated how many
genes is there within all of us
so understanding all of those genes we
we thought that we could say goodbye to
um diseases but as you all may realize
um after 18 years we still realize that
that's not the case and now we know that
lots of factors that are important in
understanding all of these things which
i outlined in my previous slide
um and so there's lots of data to
understand specifically how genome uh
how can we go from genotype to phenotype
understanding all of that
we have different layers of omics
and lots of data generated at every step
of this ladder of omics
and also um microbiomics um and also i
just like checked um wikipedia and i
think we have more than 200 and
or 300 different ohmic terms now and
this is something that i would do with
my students i walk around the class and
ask every single student to come up with
the gnomic term and uh we have
four or five times moreo mix now so
which means each one of those omics is
generating a huge amount of data
and now we all have to figure out how to
mine these data and how to generate the
next
uh generation of bioinformatician who
can actually understand all of this
and to come up with a simplistic view of
understanding how we can go from
genotype to phenotype so genomics of
course is being used to integrate
pathways mutated genes and drug drug
interactions for various different
diseases
and genomics is also
is a tool
a diagnostic tool now to understand a
molecular mechanisms of diseases
and all of these different ohmic terms
has become a standard way of looking at
everything in whatever discipline that
you are
working with
of course in the clinics
for physicians they need to embody
they need to understand all of this data
in order to be able to
uh meaningfully treat
their patients and so the idea of
precision
needs to be there and the idea of
personalization needs to be there
for the practice of medicine
so we also have realized systems
medicine is already in clinics today
uh big data use to learn about general
population to make clinical decisions um
in this um
and reproductive health reproductive
endocrinology uh prospective parents
genetic testing before and during
pregnancies tumor profiling using
genetics to tailor cancer treatments uh
by tracking mutations and trains of um
cancers in various tissues and
pharmacogenomics of course
accessing an individual's perspective
reaction to a drug based on their
specific genetic makeup of course this
is actually already in use um in the
field of cancer um and we have come a
long way
in fact there are specific drugs that
have been approved by the fda to treat
specific mutations that people may
harbor
in specific cancer types for example
colon cancer breast cancer
and all of those different things so we
have actually come a long way
and there is a revolution in medical
practice um so in now instead of
focusing more on
curing diseases we want to actually
prevent diseases from happening and also
health promotion so there is enough data
out there
but the problem is
how do we mine this data so we have to
generate um
the next generation of
scientists and biomedical
informations
uh who can actually understand this data
so this explosion of data has really
made us realize that we need educational
programs to learn this new language i
call this a new language that all of us
um
in any discipline needs to learn
and of course it's an investment and
that probably pays the best best
interest as far as some concern
so josh shang
became a one of the leaders uh to create
the first program in systems medicine
gave birth to a program a dual degree
program mdms in systems medicine
it was successfully launched
almost a decade ago in 2011
and the students are required to take 30
credits of course it's a very rigorous
curriculum
and it is specifically intended for
students in medical school
who have completed two years of their
medical training they take a year off
and then they
get a master's degree in systems
medicine and they have a dual degree um
so that they understand uh the
computational sciences genomics
proteomics and all of these momentum so
that they can actually uh make um an
intelligent
prognosis for their patients that
they're going to see so they will be a
new type of physician
who actually embrace the concept of all
of these different omics
um and of course more importantly
systems approach to medicine which is
what we all have to learn
and of course uh we also wanted to
create a master's program not
necessarily for students in medical
school because this is applicable to any
discipline
uh in the sciences um in any discipline
that people want to go to so we created
another master's program in 2016
and the program again the curriculum was
intended for any student who is
interested from any discipline of
sciences who's interested
in uh pursuing a medical career becoming
a physician or by becoming a biomedical
scientist uh who uh one with a grasp of
modern computational sciences and ohmic
technologies so that they actually
become the bridge to translate
all of these discoveries uh or make from
omic data analysis to from bench to
bedside
and of course again a systems approach
to medicine and in biomedical research
so the curriculum of this program it was
not very trivial to create one
that embodies embodies different aspects
that the students need to be trained in
um and so it
it
has different aspects
of biostatistics as is important when
you are actually talking about one
single nucleotide polymorph
polymorphism in a patient we have to
make sure that it is statistically
significant before we actually come up
with
treatment modalities
and then biomedical informatics so this
is specifically uh how do you mine
electronic health records electronic
you know patient records
and all of those things to understand a
pattern in a given population maybe
ethnic populations
and of course at the end of the day
students need to learn um
journal articles and figure out how to
interpret
journal articles
and understand a use of clinical data
and of course microbiota as i said
microbiome is actually very important
and
genomic medicine and how do you
translate all of these discoveries from
bench to brainstem which means
translational and then of course um
metabolomics is actually integral to
systems medicine because at the end of
the day anything that happens in the
body
in terms of cells and what they do is
through a pathway and and what in the
end of the day the result of a pathway
and reactions is metabolites so it's
very important to understand what these
metabolites are doing and how do you
mind these
of course the program has core courses
that students need to learn that they're
trained in fundamental aspects but also
each student may choose to
go into a different career path there
are students who want to become
physicians that are students who want to
do a phd there are students who just
want to do work in health care there are
students who just want to mine data and
learn data analysis so
the electives are geared towards
specific students interests as i said
systems medicine means precision
medicine and personalized medicine so
all the curriculum is also personalized
to
each of these students so if a student
wants to do drug design they can
take a structural biology course that
teaches them how to do drug design of
course if the you want to get into
policy
then they can take policy courses and if
they want to go and get into a lab you
can do lab courses so
all these electives are geared to a
specific interest of these students and
if person is interested in cancer for
example they can take cancer so all of
this stay is tailored um as the systems
medicine program itself is personalized
in terms of what it delivers
um and the students
can take other courses epidemiology
microbiology and emerging infection
nutrition
um and so the whole curriculum is
tailored towards what the goals career
goals of each individual student is
and
apart from the courses
uh one of the most important aspect of
the curriculum is that every single
student has a capstone or a practicum
they have they do a semester-long
research
uh that for most cases culminates in a
publication
or and of course they present a poster
and they're judged by judges in the
field and so this did really drives the
students interest
to carry what they learn in classes in
lectures to actually applying it to a
real scientific problems so this really
sums up the whole experience that each
of these students actually has
the students um work in variety of
different institutions and we are very
collaborative in nature so they can work
in national nih which is down the road
from us fta which is also down the road
from us of course students can also
partner with other institutions so
students these are all the institutions
that students have actually
done their internships in memorial sloan
catering in
new york and also students actually do
internships in industry as well in
companies
and
of course to summarize the skill sets
that the students learns from all of
these is to actually analyze big data
they learn different aspects of
next generation sequence analysis rna
sequence analysis single cell rna
sequence analysis general club um thanks
to pine biotechnology they have offered
an outstanding course to the curriculum
on machine learning
and of course students also know how to
learn
learn different aspects in the lab and
of course microbiome this is actually a
summary of all of the things that the
students learn
and there is actually something for
everyone in terms of career student girl
can go to medical school nursing schools
pa or do schools
they can do pursue phds
they've got some of the students have
gone to industry and of course they can
work in doctor's offices and of course
the mdms students actually
go and pursue and become physicians um
and so there is something for everyone
from the curriculum
and so where are the graduates now so
our graduates are in all uh different
institutions across the u.s um
pioneer institutions like cornell
um sloan catering and all of those
things um university of maryland um and
all of those things
and then of course um
every student will ask do we have
scholarships to support
um of course we do have so we have an
endowment called the robert steven
ludley endowment we were given hundred
thousand dollars for the program
and that generates some um scholarships
and also we have other scholarships all
merit-based scholarships um that
can
help you with your tuition because
georgetown is expensive um of course
it's not all about curriculum the
students also have lots of fun
we celebrate different festivals and
there's lots lots of conferences
students attend and at the end of the
day you can see smiling faces
um so there's a rich curriculum but also
there's also socializing
aspects to the program
we take field trips to nih uh here this
is a field trip to look at the
sequencing facilities and then
of course i i want to summarize why
georgetown um
the top five reasons to attend
georgetown um location it's very very
pretty and beautiful here
and of course uh traditions connect
students from all campuses past present
time the future
um and then we also have rich athletic
history as you all know hoyas saksa
and then of course we also have famous
and influential people who have loved us
in the past um
and of course you can be satisfied with
my minor things everyone should be as
should aim as big
as possibly can uh from um watson um
that's his advice to all of us
and of course our faculty and staff are
incomparable we have amazing faculty um
and who are always there
and of course the program is first in
the nation um right now and of course
you're all welcome to come right now to
visit because the cherry blossoms are in
full blossom uh right now and it is very
beautiful here
um if you want to learn more about the
program you can go to this website
systemsmedicine.com
or you can actually also email
us at systems.medicine at georgetown.edu
um
so i thank you all for your attention
and i'm very happy to take any questions
you may have
thank you so much for your talk dr
vasudem
um we have a few questions for you okay
so
um we want to know who all are eligible
to join the program there okay that's a
fantastic question
anyone who has an undergraduate degree
in the sciences or even computer science
majors
are eligible for this program
um because every single course starts
from basics so you won't be lost in any
of the programs so we have actually had
even one history major
uh who is actually been in the program
from our mbms curriculum so anyone with
a basic interest in the sciences
and has little bit of background in
sciences is eligible for the program
great thank you um another question we
have was
so thinking back to when you were first
learning and first introduced to the
field of bioinformatics which what
advice would you give yourself just
starting out
um
to uh figure i mean can you repeat that
question let me get it
um yes so um if you're looking back if
you could go back in time and ask um
give yourself advice when you were first
starting out in bioinformatics what
would you tell yourself okay so i
actually want to um currently today
um by when i started bioinformatics it
was an accident um after i finished my
phd in
a lab
doing drug design and extra
crystallography i'm a physicist by
training had no idea what even
bioinformatics meant i was accidentally
put in a lab in ncbi national center for
biotechnology information
um so at that point in time i did not
realize the the importance of
bioinformatics so when i turned my life
back
i think that was the best accident that
happened to me in my life what i would
have done is at that point in time i
would have gone and done a phd in
bioinformatics at that point in time um
so i now i'm glad that that accident
happened in my life uh because i can't
imagine what i would have done without
the training that i've actually had as
i'm standing today looking at the
evolution in the field
great thank you so much um another
question we have uh is have you
considered including some basic math
courses in the program yeah so actually
that is a very good question and we
actually do have uh so the biostatistics
course um
actually does cover a little bit of
mathematical concepts in it
and in fact all of the uh analysis that
you we do
uh all and in you know has to have a
little bit of math so we don't have
specific math geared i'm not sure um
what specific aspects that you're asking
about but most of the courses actually
embrace mathematical concepts so we do
teach little bit of mathematical concept
across different courses but not
full-fledged math courses
because of the student population that
we actually have
great thank you so much uh i think that
is all the questions that we have for
you right now
so
uh yeah again great talk we will now
begin with our next
yeah
before that can i just answer one
question that is in the chat um
it's there's a one question can a phd
guy do this program yes absolutely
um great definitely the answer is yes
thank you again great thank you all for
your time thank you so much dr vasuvadan